fabriquer de l'alcool avec ses intestins
vieillir très mais alors très lentement
avoir des mains ou des cheveux qui
vivent leur propre vie dégager une odeur
de de poisson pourri non c'est pas des
pitch de film fantastiqu c'est des
syndromes qui existe vraiment bougez pas
je reviens et on enent
parle donc aujourd'hui on va passer en
revue les syndromes les plus étranges
mais avant ça vous connaissez maintenant
petit message c'est C vidéo est
sponsorisée par skill cher vous souvenez
il avaient déjà sponsorisé une de mes
vidéos j'espère que vous avez pu tester
si c'est pas le cas attendez de secondes
j'ai un cadeau pour vous ce qu'il cher
c'est une plateforme de cours en ligne
c'est un peu comme aller en classe sauf
que les profs sont là juste pour toi et
puis surtout ça commence à l'heure que
tu veux c'est quand même vachement bien
on peut téléprendre des cours si vous
voulez il suffit de lancer la vidéo et
hop autre avantage si on a un imprévu
genre un truc urgent à faire on met sur
pause et on reprend quand on a
fini et puis surtout vous avez le choix
de suivre les cours que vous voulez il y
a plein d'activités super différentes
des cours de musique vous vous souvenez
la dernière fois j'avais pris des cours
de
batterie mais vous pouvez aussi
apprendre à cuisiner à dessiner à
utiliser plein de logiciels divers et
variés et cetera et cetera quel que soi
vos goûts et votre niveau vous allez
trouver quelque chose qui vous plaît et
qui vous convient et évidemment tout est
sous-titré en français il y a même des
profs qui parlent français des fois
carrément moi cette fois j'ai appris à
réaliser mon propre cocktail de prestige
et comme je suis sympa pour que vous
puissiez essayer je vous offre un mois
d'essaiis gratuit chez skillshare je
vous ai mis le lien dans la description
c'est sans limitation donc vous avez
accès à tous les cours de la plateforme
et vous pouvez en faire autant que vous
voulez allez cheers bon ok mais c'est
syndrome mystérieux là c'est quoi et ben
je vous propose de vous en expliquer CIN
et on commence tout de suite avec le
syndrome d'ylander ok la rêve date un
peu vous connaissez Christophe Lambert
bah oui non voilà bon en fait tout ce
que vous avez à savoir c'est que dans
Highlander le héros est immortel attends
du coup le le syndrome d'lander ça veut
dire qu'on est non le syndrome d'lander
ça veut pas dire qu'on est immortel ça
veut dire qu'on vieillit plus lentement
attends mais c'est trop bien de pas
vieillir ah moi je veux bien ah bah si
ah bah ben non tenez ce jeune coréen en
pyjama là vous lui donnez quel âge 12 13
ans Max perdu le double dans cette vidéo
Yong Yung Shin c'est son nom il a 26 ans
et il mesure 1 M63 parce que le syndrome
d'ylander ça ralentit le vieillissement
mais ça ralentit aussi la croissance et
puis bon il aime faire la fête il aime
dans
il aime aller en boîte de nuit avec ses
amis qui ont le même âge que lui mais
pour lui c'est pas forcément facile
d'être crédible c'est Mme déjà pas
forcément très facile de rentrer en
boîte j'imagine donc bah c'est pas
vraiment une bonne nouvelle de paraître
la moitié de son âge pas à cet âge là en
tout cas alors aujourd'hui yomyungchine
il a 34 ans et la bonne nouvelle c'est
que en dehors de son retard de
croissance et de puberté les médecins
estiment que son syndrome a eu aucun
autre effet sur sa santé par contre
personne comprend encore le pourquoi et
le comment les médecins cherchent encore
des explications un truc qui est sûr par
contre c'est que ça n'a rien à voir avec
le cas d'une Américaine qui s'appelle
chonary et qui avait l'air d'avoir 8 ans
quand elle en avait 22 chez elle c'était
une tumeur au niveau de l'hypophyse qui
est l'organe qui sécrète notamment
l'hormone de croissance et la chimio qui
a été utilisée pour soigner cette tumeur
qui était en cause donc même conséquence
mais pas du tout même cause donc pour
l'instant ce syndrome on sait juste que
c'est l'inverse de la progériia vous
savez cette maladie qui fait vieillir
beaucoup plus vite on sait aussi que
contrairement à yomyung Shin la plupart
des patientes et des patients qui ont
été atteints par ce syndrome ils avaient
aussi des retards mentaux qui étaient
parfois très très lourds et que certains
n'ont pas vécu très longtemps et on sait
aussi que c'est très très rare parce
qu'il y aurait que se cas de syndrome
d'ylander répertorié dans le monde
entier d'ailleurs c'est tellement rare
que la maladie en vrai elle a pas de nom
le coup d'lander là c'est une invention
des médias mensongsong le syndrome des
cheveux incoiffables pili triangoui et
canaloui c'est pas le nom d'un groupe de
polyphonicorse c'est le vrai nom du
syndrome des cheveux incoiffables parce
que oui c'est un vrai syndrome il a été
découvert en 1973 par un dermato
toulousain et il atteint les enfants
entre 3 mois et 12 ans leurs cheveux ils
deviennent progressivement blonds
argentés sec comme de la paille et
impossible à coiffer correctement ils
sont toujours hsut et bourrifé si vous
voulez comme un bad herd mais tous les
jours mais pas forcément pour toujours
par contre parce que ça se soigne pas
mais en général ça s'arrange en
grandissant on sait pas exa exactement
combien de personnes ça touche mais on
sait que c'est rare et ça touche que les
cheveux il y a pas d'autres conséquences
sur la santé en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que si on observe les cheveux des
enfants comme ça au microscope on se
rend compte qu'ils ont une forme
triangulaire au lieu d'être ronde et qu'
a comme une espèce de petite gouttière
sur toute leur longueur d'où le nom pili
triangoui et
canalicoui cheveux triangulair et
canaliculaire ok mais pourquoi ça
qu'est-ce qu'il leur prend aux cheveux
là et ben c'est encore une équipe de
chercheurs Toulous qui a trouveré la
réponse ils ont un truc apparemment avec
les cheveux é bourifés à Toulouse c'est
la mutation de trois gènes qui est en
cause déjà il y a un gène qui est
impliqué dans la fabrication d'un des
principaux composants qui structurent
nos cheveux la tricoyaline et deux
autres gènes qui sont eux à l'origine de
la fabrication d'enzym qui s'attaquent à
cette même substance conséquence directe
la tige pilaire le cheveux quoi elle
prend cette forme particulière et elle
devient plus rigide donc comme j'ai dit
he ça a pas d'autres conséquences que ça
c'est pas dangereux pour la santé mais
ça peut être embêtant si on l'assume pas
bien c'est juste un truc d'apparence
mais voilà ça peut être compliqué à
gérer quoi à moins de vivre dans les
années 80 bien sûr là c'est là c'est OK
ou dans les années 2000 remarquez mais
bon là faut faire une couleur et tout
c'est un peu plus compliqué quand même
le syndrome d'autobrasserie le syndrome
d'autobrasserie comme son nom l'indique
c'est quand votre corps se transforme en
brasserie ah genre il devient pas
aimable et il sert des cafés trop cher
c'est ça je comprends le mais non un
indice on appelle ça aussi le syndrome
d'autofermentation et j'en ai déjà parlé
sur la chaîne d'une bière et j'y vais ça
fait deux indices et ben ouais les gens
qui ont un autowery syndrome un ABS
comme on dit leurs intestins se
transformment en alambique ou en
fermenteur oui leur corps fabrique de
l'alcool je vous explique dans nos
intestins mais j'en ai parlé dans ma
dernière vidéo donc allez la voir on a
tout un tas de bestioles qui composent
notre microbiote intestinale des
bactéries des virus et des champignons
et parmi ces champignons il y a des
levures et parmi ces Lure il y en a qui
s'appelle les sakaromicè sevisiaé et ok
c'est chiant des sakaromic serevisiaé
donc sakaro comme sucre serevisiaé comme
serveroise
ca su trilingue de la levure de bière
capable de transformer des glucides en
alcool c'est un médecin japonais qui a
découvert ça en 1952 en constatant qu'il
y avait certaines personnes qui était
complètement bourré quand elle mangeait
trop de riz bah oui parce que le riz
c'est plein d'amidon l'amidon c'est un
glucide et et on a vu ce qu'elle leur
faisait au glucides les levures elle les
transforme en alcool et après l'alcool
bah il reste pas là il passe dans le
sang et après bah voilà vous connaissez
on raconte n'importe quoi on a mal au
ventre on a envie de vomir le lendemain
on a la gueule de bois et cetera et
cetera donc ce médecin il a décrit bah
ce phénomène là et il a appeler ça le
may show qui est aussi le nom d'un
groupe d'aphrobites voilà ça c'est
cadeau c'est pour VO la péter en soirée
mais alors pourquoi tout le monde
dise-il pas de l'alcool avec ses
intestins bah oui parce que ces levures
là on en a quasi toutes et tous dans les
boyaux sauf qu'en général il y en a très
peu donc ça génère une quantité infime
d'alcool mais les gens atteints du
syndrome d'autobrasserie ils en ont
beaucoup plus que la moyenne donc si en
plus ils avalent beaucoup de glucid du
riz ou autre chose et ben ça fait tous
les ingrédients nécessaires pour générer
jusqu'à l'équivalent de 7 verre d'alcool
fort ah bah yes une petite cuite
gratuite ah c'est bon ça attends e oh
oui mais non même si c'est une maladie
rare ça a quand même posé des problèmes
parfois très graves à certaines
personnes quand ça a touché des enfants
par exemple vous imaginez bien que ou
dans le cas encore plus particulier
d'une Américaine de 61 ans à qui on a
refusé une greffe de fois parce que ces
analyses montraient des traces
importantes d'alcool la pauvre femme
elle avait beau promettre que non elle
buvait pas les médecins il préféraent
croire les résultats d'analyse jusqu'au
moment où ils se sont rendus compte que
oui elle avait de l'alcool dans les
urines mais pas dans le sang vous voyez
le convouvenir non bah oui elle elle
avait des levures pas dans les intestins
mais dans la V c'était un cas encore
plus rare de ce qu'on appelle le
syndrome d'autobrasserie urinaire si
vous voulez savoir les chercheurs
pensent qu'il peut y avoir deux causes
au syndrome d'autobrasserie soit c'est
génétique c'est comme ça soit c'est un
déséquilibre du microbiote après une
prise d'antibiotique voilà donc on sait
comment ces gens arrivent à fabriquer de
l'alcool avec leurs intestins par contre
je sais pas vous mais moi je me demande
à quoi ressemble leur caca mon chéri
osez son intensité le syndrome du miroir
le syndrome du miroir c'est une
particularité neurologique qui touche
les mains et ça n'a rien à voir avec ce
qu'on appelle la main en miroir qui est
une anomalie congénitale donc là on
parle d'un syndrome qui touche le
mouvement des mains non vous voyez pas
ok je vous dis si vous êtes atteint du
syndrome des mouvements en miroir quand
vous faites un geste avec une main
l'autre ne peut pas s'empêcher de faire
le même en même temps et vous pouvez
rien y faire devient complètement
incontrôlable c'est handicapant
évidemment parce que quand vous avez ça
vous pouvez pas faire deux choses
différentes avec chacune de vos mains
comme jouer de la batterie par exemple
ou plein d'autres trucs hein je quoi
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe là-dedans
exactement bah faut savoir que notre
cerveau il a deux côtés deux hémisphères
qui ont une petite partie parularité
c'est l'hémisphère gauche qui commande
le côté droit de notre corps et
l'hémisphère droit qui commande le côté
gauche oui parce que nos nerfs qui sont
chargés de nos mouvements ils partent de
nos hémisphères cérébraux et puis ils se
croisent au niveau de ce qu'on appelle
le Tron cérébral et dans le cas de ce
syndrome c'est comme s'il y avait une
partie des nerfs qui contrôle nos mains
qui prenaient la bonne direction au
croisement et une autre partie quiue
tout droit et du coup les hémisphères
commandent les deux mains au lieu d'une
seule c'est une maladie génétique et il
y a des chercheurs qui qui ont réussi à
isoler le gène responsable en comparant
l'ADN de membres de deux familles
différentes qui avaient tous le syndrome
le gène en question il influence
l'activité d'une protéine qui s'appelle
la nétrine qui est chargée de guider nos
neurones donc nos nerfs si vous voulez
quand il se développe donc quand on est
des fétus et les chercheurs ont
déterminé que quand ce gène mute la
nétrine elle arrive plus à faire son
boulot correctement et elle indique mal
le chemin à nonner voilà maintenant il y
a plus qu'à trouver comment on peut
réparer ça mais le neurologue qui a
découvert ça il s'appelle le professeur
flamon rose je suis neurologue
spécialisé dans les maladies du
mouvement moi je trouve que c'est
porteur
d'espoir le syndrome de l'odeur de
poisson pourri bon là ça va être
difficile de faire du teasing tout est
littéralement dans le nom quand on a le
syndrome de l'odeur de poisson pourri et
ben on sent le poisson pourri le nom un
petit peu plus scientifique et un petit
peu moins stigmatisant de la maladie
c'est la triméthylaminurie parce que le
problème vient d'une substance qui
s'appelle la triméthylamine qui a une
composition assez proche de celle de
l'ammoniaque mais qui sent bah poisson
pourri voilà sa cette substance on en
produit naturellement essentiellement en
dégradant certains aliments mais
normalement on a aussi une enzyme qui
s'appelle la monooxygénase à flavine 3
ça se lappète toujours un petit peu avec
les noms les enzymes he je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué cette enzyme elle va
dégrader à son tour la triméthyamine qui
va disparaître donc hop on en parle plus
ça sent la violette la violette pas
toujours hein quand même mais au moins
ça sent pas le slep après une semaine de
festoche sans prendre de douche les
personnes qui ont le syndrome qui nous
intéresse elles ont un déficit en
monooxygénase à fl flavine 3 la fameuse
enzyme qui se laappète donc la
triméthylamine elle est pas dégradée
elle s'accumule et elle finit par être
évacuer dans les urines la transpiration
mais aussi la respiration donc la laine
et ça se soigne pas vraiment on peut
juste limiter la casse en évitant les
aliments incriminés par exemple et en
évitant de transpirer mais il y a aussi
d'autres trucs qui permettent d'atténuer
les odeurs il y a d'autres maladies
comme ça qui donnent des odeurs très
particulières on pourra en reparler une
autre fois si ça vous dit d'ailleurs
hésitez pas à me dire si ça vous dit non
mais pas là dans les commentaires je
veux dire voilà DTC c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien